[Musique]
il était une fois et il y a encore quelque chose de caché
parmi les glaciers de l'Antarctique
montagne creuse qui, selon la légende
garde le secret sur les origines
de l'homme
au coeur de la montagne se trouve une grotte
ça ressemble à l'intérieur d'une coquille
noyer et sur ses murs sont gravés des dieux
des symboles qui racontent l'histoire
de l'humanité
[Musique]
au milieu de la grotte dans le silence plus
absolu domine une table massive
rotonde creusée dans la roche
est un lieu sacré, cette table est-elle la
noble objectif de ne pas avoir de premier
dernière place parce que les êtres vivants
ils sont tous égaux face à la luxure
le créateur de notre univers
brava est l'une des entités appartenant à
une civilisation cosmique à l'infini
évolué si avancé qu'il a échappé au
limites de notre compréhension
nous, les Terriens, considérons ces entités
comme des dieux parce que nous sommes trop
arriérés pour comprendre comment et pourquoi
ont conçu la réalité tangible e
les étoiles
qu'avec leur énergie
permettre la vie sur certaines planètes, les dieux
divers univers
[Musique]
parce qu'il y a d'autres univers
également composé de milliards de
planètes étoiles galaxies quelques dieux
qui sont habités par d'autres êtres et
d'autres types d'hommes
mais dans notre univers
la conception de la matière vivante est
été confié à la cupidité
la légende raconte qu'il a envie
il somnolait dans une dimension sans
espace et intemporel quand
soudain le son de om
prolongé et puissant l'a réveillé de
commencer
[Musique]
soutien-gorge mais il savait qu'il reviendrait dans son
moment mais il était toujours confus, il ne savait pas
ce qu'il faut faire
puis son épouse Saraswati que le
divinité féminine sans laquelle rien
peut être réalisé suggéré qu'il reste
se taire et écouter
tellement immergé dans le son de l'ombre
conçu l'ordre cosmique
un ensemble de lois physiques biologiques
et une éthique qui préservent la vie pour le
durée d'un cycle renouvelable
sans cesse
appelé le jour de brahma
[Musique]
parmi les nombreux êtres déjà complets et
perfectionner toutes leurs facultés que tu
manifesté comme par magie dans le nôtre
l'univers sur la planète Terre est apparu
l'homme est une créature dotée d'un
conscience et triade qui l'accompagne dans
toute sa vie et cela lui permet de
atteindre le summum de la conscience
les symboles gravés dans cette montagne creuse
ils ne sont perçus en vision que par
très peu de mystiques qui les gardent
secrets
pourtant tous les croyants sont athées, je
philosophes et scientifiques du monde
ils prétendent connaître les origines
de l'homme
certains pensent qu'il a été créé par
une divinité pour gouverner la terre
d'autres nient l'intervention divine
expliquant que l'homme est un animal
traitant et que son aspect soit plus
trivialement dû à une évolution
naturel voire même aléatoire
l'une des plus anciennes théories selon lesquelles
Medica est née en Inde il y a plus de 5000 ans
il y a et est décrit dans les quatre livres de
voir écrit en sanskrit
[Musique]
les Vedas déclarent que chaque personne est
doté d'une conscience éternelle et quand
le corps de cette personne meurt
la conscience se réincarne dans le corps d'un
nouveau née
[Musique]
les textes védiques mentionnent également des avatars
des divinités venues sur terre pour
expliquer aux humains comment ça marche
l'ordre cosmique
et comment améliorer votre vie
s'appuyer sur les pouvoirs de la spiritualité
une autre culture
tout aussi ancien que le sumérien
[Musique]
la différence entre les deux cultures est que
celui que vous voyez est basé sur des textes
connu et étudié depuis 5000 ans
tandis que le sumérien a été découvert
au 19ème siècle et ses textes gravés sur
les tablettes d'argile sont connues et
étudié pendant un peu plus d'un siècle
[Musique]
la littérature supposera que les dieux
des géants venus du ciel à bord
les machines volantes sont arrivées
terre pour exploiter ses richesses
exploitation minière
leur équipage était composé de
nobles et des subordonnés et quand ceux-ci
a refusé pour la dernière fois de travailler dans
les mines, les nobles les remplaçèrent par des dieux
Des primates africains qui se sont améliorés
génétiquement modifié pour en faire un nouveau
l'espèce s'appelle l'homme, le terrien
[Musique]
autrement dit si les géants subalternes
ils ne s'étaient pas rebellés
l'homme n'apparaîtrait jamais
selon le récit sumérien, ceux
les astronautes géants ont vécu des milliers de
années
ils possédaient une technologie supérieure et
ils étaient donc tenus pour acquis
divinité dès les premiers hommes qui furent
très dur
mais aussi flatté d'être
considérés comme des dieux les géants
ils traitaient les hommes comme des esclaves
ils exigeaient une obéissance absolue e
ils ont tué et désobéi
c'est ainsi que les notions de
punition divine et religieuse
[Musique]
mais j'ai des difficultés
respirer sur une planète qui n'existait pas
leurs géants ont été forcés de
vivre au sommet des montagnes où
l'air est plus mince
mais ces endroits n'étaient guère
accessible par les humains alors je
les géants ont amélioré certains hommes
primitifs formant une lignée d'hommes
supérieur loin des mythes et construit
des très hauts immeubles sur lesquels
le haut leur a donné des ordres à faire
suivre les esclaves
[Musique]
puis ils formèrent les premières nations et
ils ont dicté à leurs amis qui sont les
ancêtres des sumériens les textes gravés sur
comprimés
dans ces textes, les géants me décrivent
leurs voyages dans le système solaire et le
la production de l'homme qui leur est faite
image et ressemblance
[Musique]
même les textes égyptiens anciens mentionnent
divinités géantes semblables à celles
sur les mers qui ont créé les premiers hommes
dans la Grèce antique, il y a plus de deux mille ans
à la fin, il y a trois mille ans, Homère aussi
et desio mentionnent des divinités qui
ils ressemblent beaucoup à ceux d'ici et ça
créer à travers le premier homme et le premier
femme
[Musique]
le premier à mentionner un seul dieu e
Zarathoustra, un mystique des temps anciens
la perse prêche à la suite
de la vie humaine au paradis
en enfer
cette idée est immédiatement partagée par
peuple juif naissant qui depuis lors
embrasser la foi monothéiste
[Musique]
les textes hébreux précédant celui-ci
la conversion raconte les mêmes faits
gravé deux mille ans plus tôt dans le
Tablettes sumériennes
ils excitent donc les géants vénérés en
le Moyen-Orient les appelle elohim
[Musique]
mais après l'avènement du monothéisme, ceux
les textes sont en panne pour compiler les
Bible juive un livre saint où si
prétend que le seul créateur elohim
de l'univers de la terre et de l'homme
le hub est le dieu guerrier des Juifs
on ne sait pas si les divinités prennent le relais
Indien
juif
grec
Chinois et les autres divinités mentionnées dans le
les mythes du monde antique sont les mêmes
parce qu'ils sont très similaires mais pas
ils se comportent tous de la même manière
régnait dans la vallée de l'Indus
spiritualité
guerre au Moyen-Orient
culture en Chine
en Egypte le culte de l'au-delà
quatre siècles plus tard au Népal
Bouddha suit la tradition védique
arguant que la vie n'a pas de commencement
une fin et que les gens se réincarnent
jusqu'à ce qu'ils deviennent des esprits et des terriens
libre de souffrance
en Chine, même Lao Tze a une conception
cycle d'existence où l'homme ne
il vient du fait que le sien a toujours existé
la tâche est de revenir sur scène
origine qui l'a généré
[Musique]
six cents ans plus tard, en Palestine, le juif
Inspirateur romain du christianisme
Paul de Tarse
déclare l'existence d'un nouveau dieu
Jésus
[Musique]
l'homme et Dieu Jésus a été envoyé
terre pour que son sacrifice sur
traverser pour commencer une nouvelle humanité
basé sur le pardon et l'amour du vin
Encore 600 ans passent et moins
l'influence de la culture juive voisine
est né en Arabie de la religion
monothéiste de l'islam dont le seul dieu
également créateur de l'univers de
la terre et l'homme sont très similaires à l'ave
le dieu des Juifs
[Musique]
il existe de nombreuses divinités mentionnées par les différents
textes sacrés du monde mais bien qu'il y ait
sont des preuves historiques de leur
existence
leurs croyants les vénèrent en se basant
sur ses perceptions intérieures et plus encore
les conservateurs recourent à la violence pour
convertissez ceux qui n'y croient pas
[Musique]
du XVIIIe siècle à la suite de
atrocités perpétrées par l'Église
catholique avec l'inquisition le dieu
la spiritualité est contestée en europe
la théorie matérialiste est née
[Musique]
cette théorie soutient que la création
de l'univers est dû à une explosion
original
que la vie est née d'une combinaison
chimie aléatoire
et que chaque être vivant est le produit
de l'évolution spontanée de l'être
du même ordre qui le précède
[Musique]
la théorie la plus célèbre est celle de Darwin
qui contourne la question de l'origine
de la vie en l'expliquant avec l'évolution
d'une cellule primordiale qui a alors
formé des corps plus complexes
bien que Darwin lui-même admette que
cette théorie a des difficultés
s'appliquer à l'homme
et la bague n'a jamais été retrouvée
il ne manque aucune plante ni personne
animal
[Musique]
des doutes sur l'évolution darwinienne
découlent également des études réalisées sur
certains organes comme les yeux et les ailes
qui n'ont pas évolué du tout parce que
ils ont toujours été parfaitement actifs
Depuis le début
contribuer à la défense du darwinisme
principalement les Britanniques qui recherchent
colonisé les autres continents e
traduit leurs œuvres littéraires davantage
les gens importants ont pris soin de ne pas
les divulguer
surtout la littérature hindoue
héritier du médical car son
révélations de nature spirituelle
bouleverserait la culture occidentale
d'origine anglo-saxonne
maintenant deviens un matérialiste e
scientifique
en fait, on a découvert que les ancêtres
des hindous maîtrisaient tous les
disciplines scientifiques bien avant
Les Grecs étaient considérés comme les pères du savoir
il y a cinq mille ans, les textes védiques
ils ont parlé de manipulation génétique
les chiffres et zéro puis copiés à partir de
Arabes
ils ont mentionné des machines volantes qui
ils ont parcouru l'espace et soutenu
l'existence d'autres civilisations humaines qui
a précédé l'actuel
[Musique]
ces civilisations étaient dotées de
des technologies bien supérieures à celles
actuel
leurs traces sont encore visibles dans
cette immense construction que la nôtre
les ingénieurs ne peuvent pas correspondre et tout
cela réduit la primauté de
Culture occidentale
[Musique]
il semble que la civilisation d'avant
notre ère mondiale et pacifique avec un
seule langue en sanscrit aujourd'hui détenue
la base de nombreuses langues disparues
[Musique]
la littérature médicale l'explique bien
de détails l'existence d'autrui
univers
de leurs galaxies de planètes habitées
d'autres humanoïdes dont certains ont
déjà visité la terre
de la conscience et de la triade qui les anime
et des intelligences cosmiques qu'ils sont
à la base de la création
les vedas mentionnent également les évolutions et les
involutions des univers le
apparitions et extinctions massives de
actions parallèles
effets quantiques
temps non linéaire et autres notions a
pour le moins fascinant
[Musique]
l'un d'eux explique que les cycles de chacun
la civilisation humaine a quatre ans
de l'homme
enfance et jeunesse
maturité
et la vieillesse
le premier cycle et la préhistoire
la seconde est la protohistoire avec
l'invention de l'écriture
dans ces deux cycles ce sont les divinités
les femmes pour régner en paix sur
recherche intérieure
aux troisième et quatrième cycles, ils sont
les dieux mâles et leurs armes e
régner
c'est la période des guerres comme la quatrième
cycle dans lequel nous vivons actuellement
et c'est aussi l'affrontement entre les
les pouvoirs du mal et ceux du bien avec moi
le bien qui triomphe au dernier moment et
préparer le terrain pour les quatre nouveaux
des cycles où tout recommence
très important pour le roi et aussi pour le
régime végétarien à base de légumes crus
et les fruits indispensables à un juste
l'équilibre physique et mental et pour le
respect pour la vie de nos frères
animaux qui, s'ils sont produits e
massacré en masse pour se nourrir
ils empoisonnent l'air et l'eau ainsi que
provoquer des maladies dégénératives et mortelles
en effet
manger de la viande, c'est assimiler
une substance toxique que les animaux
y compris l'homme et mis dans le sang
quand ils réalisent qu'ils sont en train d'être tués
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans cet instant de terreur, un
glande libre dans le sang du
victime cette drogue qui continue son
effet sur l'organisme de ceux qui en mangent
remuant dans le cœur et l'esprit jusqu'à
fais-les éclater
[Musique]
cela était connu de Pythagore et du
érudits de leur temps qu'ils étaient
végétariens et qui avaient pris exemple
de la spiritualité se consacre à méditer un
calmer l'esprit en acquérant ces connaissances
scientifiques et initiatiques qui en ont
rendu célèbre
[Musique]
le dernier mais non le moindre
notions médicales et la récitation du om
qui permet au corps humain de se réinitialiser
vos propres vibrations jusqu'à ce que vous les fassiez
optimale favorisant ainsi la vie de qui
le récite et de ceux qui le fréquentent
au contraire le matérialisme occidental
et la foi dans le dieu de l'argent désormais exporté
partout dans le monde, ils tendent à la décadence
de l'humanité comme le prétend le
scientifiques modernes selon lesquels le
notre QI est debout
régresser
l'intelligence est définie comme
capacité à raisonner sur les difficultés e
pour les résoudre avec des actions concrètes
mais au quatrième cycle, ces capacités sont
déléguer et intelligence artificielle le
dont le but est de remplacer l'homme
avec des robots
reproduire l'intelligence humaine
ils appellent ça le progrès mais c'est pour
Vraiment
il est logique qu'en supprimant le man le
compétences intellectuelles et manuelles
nous le rendons stupide et c'est exactement ce que
ça arrive
il reste à déterminer s'il s'agit d'un
déclin naturel ou la volonté de
quelqu'un qui agit par tous les moyens
pour que ceux qui deviendront stupides
veut subjuguer
la question n'est pas anodine
il ne serait même pas nécessaire de le faire
des divinités ou des extraterrestres pour le faire
une élite d'hommes riches suffirait e
sans scrupules qu'ils aient ça
ambitions alors lesquelles devraient être faites
qui prodigue les anciens Romains disaient
à qui profite sinon qui gagne
[Musique]
l'histoire ancienne et l'histoire actuelle sont
plein de gens méchants qui ont
conditionné la vie des peuples afin de
devenir riche
[Musique]
avec de l'argent on peut faire beaucoup de choses
comme allonger le sien
vie
ceci est déjà décrit dans les mythes anciens
parce que s'il est vrai que le temps est cyclique
tout revient
aujourd'hui ces quelques milliardaires qui gouvernent
le monde concentre son attention
sur le transhumanisme qui augmente la
capacités physiques et mentales
en plus de supprimer la vieillesse
le leur, bien sûr, certainement pas celui-là
du reste de l'humanité qui ne peut pas
se le permettre
même la Bible accepte une durée de
de nombreuses vies centenaires pour les patriarches
de souche adamique qui étaient peu nombreuses et
très riche a gardé une apparence
mineurs jusqu'à la mort et leur
mais les femmes accouchaient avec succès
centenaires
selon la Bible en Palestine à ceux
des fois il y avait yahvé qui aimait les autres dieux
Les Sumériens exigeaient des sacrifices humains et
il traitait les gens comme des animaux
mais il a favorisé les Adams plutôt qu'eux
autrefois ils considéraient les gens ordinaires
comme des êtres inférieurs
il semble presque qu'aujourd'hui la relation entre
les anciens dieux extraterrestres sont à eux
privilégiés et le reste de l'humanité oui
répéter
cette idée est d'actualité car quelques mois
il y a quelque temps, la NASA l'a officiellement admis
l'existence incontestable du web
phénomènes aérospatiaux non identifiés
anciennement appelés ovnis
des objets volants sont-ils ramassés par
radars militaires et civils tandis
traverse le ciel et les eaux des dieux
des mers à des vitesses qui échappent aux lois
physique connue
et ce ne sont pas des objets terrestres autrement
leurs fondations seraient facilement
repéré par des satellites espions
chaque centimètre carré du monde
[Musique]
l'un des directeurs de centres les plus estimés
les Israéliens de l'espace révèlent même
que les États-Unis et l'État de
Israël est en contact depuis de nombreuses années
avec des extraterrestres
installé sur mars et la lune
nous sommes dans de la pure science fiction
mais encore plus sagaces les conquérants du
passé comme Jules César Charlemagne ou
Charles Quint
aurait considéré comme de la science-fiction le
vol d'un avion
sans parler de celui d'un missile terrestre
avion ou navette
[Musique]
il n'en reste pas moins qu'extra terrestre ou pas
99 pour cent de la population
monde et aujourd’hui subjugué par un per
des centaines d'hommes très riches qui
ils aspirent au pouvoir total
et pour ce faire, ils doivent me faire taire
peuples prêts des grandes civilisations
les anciens sont les seuls à avoir les compétences
intellectuel et spirituel pour les obscurcir
s'opposer à leur culture
ce n'est pas une coïncidence si l'Inde et l'Irak la
Grèce, Italie, France et Chine
sont parmi tous les pays de la terre, je
les plus touchés par les dirigeants actuels
Ennemis anglo-saxons du spiritualisme
et défenseurs de la théorie matérialiste
basé sur l'économie
[Musique]
le sous-continent indien a été envahi
il est divisé en deux pays rendus très pauvres
l’inde et le pakistan, tous deux berceaux de
Civilisation spirituelle védique
L'Irak a été détruit et avec lui le
des traces rappelant la grande première
civilisation humaine qui se moque des sumériens
pas même le contenu des comprimés
[Musique]
Grèce, berceau de la civilisation
L'Union européenne a été pillée et placée en
genou
L'Italie est devenue un laboratoire où
l'élite mondialiste peut tester jusqu'où
il est possible de resserrer l'étau
parce que c'est ici qu'est né l'Empire romain
l'humanisme et la renaissance e
surtout la religion catholique
où il y a encore des cardinaux aujourd'hui
qui défendent la vraie spiritualité
Ennemi chrétien du matérialisme
si l'Italie tombe et que la porte s'ouvre e
on peut dire que l'expérience mondiale est réussie
immédiatement après l'Italie, ce sera le tour de
France
parce que l'héritier historique des nouveautés
La culture italienne et est dangereuse
parce que ce sont des gens très pragmatiques et
utilisé pour se rebeller avec des armes
[Applaudissements]
berceau en porcelaine du plus ancien du monde
la nounou vue a été droguée pour la première fois
avec l'oeil puis exploité en forçant
travail sous-payé et enfin
je me suis battu quand c'était trop
riche
aujourd'hui la nouvelle alliance anglo-saxonne
composé des États-Unis et du Royaume-Uni
Canada Australie et Nouvelle-Zélande
dirige ses bombes atomiques vers le
Chine
reste la Russie qui est une nation
Chrétien très croyant et riche en
carburants
mais c'est trop étendu pour risquer
l'envahir
Les Anglo-Saxons sont plutôt intelligents
ne pas commettre les mêmes erreurs que
Napoléon et Hitler
puis ils le menacent en armant les pays qui
l'entourer
et je l'ai frappé avec l'embargo une mesure
administratif et militaire qui empêche
la libre circulation des marchandises et
croissance économique
[Musique]
bref, notre quatrième cycle
on dirait un enfer
la classe moyenne disparaît
et les pauvres augmentent considérablement
le taux de natalité est étouffé et avec lui le
développement nécessaire à la maintenance
de la société
des millions de jeunes Africains viennent
déversé en Europe
déstabiliser leur culture et
notre
les grèves politiquement correctes en
chemin ridicule vers la littérature
l'homosexualité est un laissez-passer pour
le succès
[Musique]
les lois constitutionnelles sont ignorées e
conquis les droits humains et sociaux
avec deux siècles de luttes syndicales
sont supprimés
et le chaos
ou comme diraient les beaus de et se battent
finale entre les forces du mal et celles
du bien
[Musique]
comment ça va finir, raconte l'histoire
et l'art
La peinture de Raphaël est bien connue
sanzio où l'archange michael
écraser la tête de satan
symbolisé par un dragon
on sait également que lorsque peu
les privilégiés sont abordés par un
les gens en colère finissent généralement mal
comme cela s'est déjà produit avec la révolution
Français et avec tous les autres
révolutions du monde
[Musique]
mais pour sortir du chaos ils existent
d'autres solutions
Autres méthodes
[Musique]
gandhi par exemple en s'appuyant sur
Sagesse védique et non-violence
persuadé 300 millions d'Indiens
croiser les bras
obligeant les Britanniques à revenir
Maison
[Musique]
Nelson Mandela a été enfermé dans un
cellule pendant 30 ans et j'en suis sorti
fortifié grâce à des études voir
ce qui lui a donné la force de
vaincre la ségrégation raciale
Martin Luther King a embrassé Al
vérisme pour obtenir la parité
droits des Afro-Américains
et autrefois tous les grands initiés
comme Dante Alighieri
pic de la mirandole
Léonard de Vinci
et Michel-Ange a suivi les principes
fondamentaux de la culture de la voile
les représentant dans leurs œuvres
pour conclure tous les êtres vivants
du plus grand au plus petit, ils sont
créatures infiniment complexes
impossible de rester en vie sans
un projet initial très élaboré e
cohérent qu'aucun scientifique ne pourra
ne réalise jamais
[Musique]
et pourtant quelque chose d'immensément
le supérieur l'a fait et continue de le faire
le dire serait déjà un point de
assez de départ
[Musique]
la meilleure chose à faire est peut-être
redécouvrez le pouvoir de l'ancien
la spiritualité consacre
qui conseille de surmonter les difficultés
régime végétarien et jeu d'acteur
du om dont l'action vit et favorise
contact avec l'intelligence cosmique
[Musique]
essayez et le monde sera à nouveau
certainement mieux